Important immigration update
The US Senate is about to vote on a Bill on Wednesday,
February 7th,
that's gonna clamp down and make it harder
across the southern border for migrants
and at the same time
increase legal immigration to the United States
by 250,000 green cards.
First, the president of the United States
is gonna be given authority to shut down the border
once more than 4,000 people per day
start crossing over it.
By law, more than 5,000 per day cross over
it will be automatically closed.
Second, they're gonna make it harder to apply for asylum,
and they're gonna process asylum claims in six months
so there's no more
come to the United States,
apply for asylum
and get a work permit
and wait years and years and years for an interview
and grow your roots in the United States.
And the appeal process is gonna be limited
in the courts.
The appeal process is gonna be done through
the department of Homeland Security.
In return for harder asylum
and clamping down on the border,
The United States is going to be giving
250,000 more green cards
to eligible people
who are on the waiting list for green cards
through family sponsorship and employment sponsorship.
That means the backlogs of waiting
years and years and years
will be substantially reduced.
And as a throw in
children who are on H4 visas
dependent on their parents.
H1B visas will not age out once they turn 21 years old.
Second, you have to understand
the Politics behind all of this.
This immigration Bill is tied to aid to Ukraine
and aid to Israel.
Why? Because Republicans said
they will not give another dollar to Israel
or to Ukraine
until the United States secures its own border
on the Mexican US border. Second,
it needs 60 senators to pass the Bill.
Presumably, 51 Democrats, presumably,
will vote for it.
And there's enough Republican leadership.
60 senators,
at least nine Republicans,
to vote for it
if it passes.
And there's no guarantee.
That's when it gets dicey,
because the Republican presidential candidate,
presumed presidential candidate
Donald Trump,
says he doesn't want an immigration Bill.
Why? Because he wants to campaign against Joe Biden
on his poor record with immigration.
So he wants the border to remain as open as possible
to show the US public
that Joe Biden can't control the border.
If the Bill passes the US Senate,
it's gonna go to the house of representatives.
The House Majority Leader
for the house of Representatives,
Mike Johnson,
says this Bill is dead on arrival. Now,
two things may happen if the Senate passes this Bill.
One, many in the house of representatives will cave
and say, okay,
let's pass this Bill
if it looks like they're gonna be the cause of
rampant immigration across the southern border.
Or 2, there may be a negotiation to lower the threshold
on the number of people who have to cross the border
before it automatically shuts down.
And they may Negotiate the end of
all of those Parole programs in order to get a deal.
It's important to a lot of politicians
to look strong on immigration.
It's important to a lot of politicians to give aid to
Israel and Ukraine.
So there's a lot of moving parts here
as a backdrop to all of this.
The American public has the perception,
right or wrong,
that there is a surge in crime
due to the migrant crisis,
of people running across the border.
And fuel was added to that fire just this past weekend
when a group of alleged migrants
was caught on camera in Times Square in New York City
beating up several police officers.
So there's a lot going on here.
I'll keep you updated as I know more.